it was so nice working with you we got
to work together during the Super Bowl
yeah a couple days beforehand when we
did a segment with Tom Brady and some of
the other players and it was really fun
you were very funny
it was nice hanging out with you I gotta
get you on the show I had such a good
time with you and then of course Tom
Brady had to show up which was such a
bummer because then the focus went to
him and I was like hello over here
too bad the game stopped no I can't
believe I made out with him for ten
minutes but he showed up and it with the
angels started singing I was looking for
Giselle she wasn't there and then the
interview was awesome it was so great
really good time yeah thank you for
helping us that was stop of course I was
just too bad you didn't get away with
stealing the jersey right that was your
idea you know I wanted to talk about
that because you have was my plot I was
curious about this tell us what you know
because it seems like a strange story
the story came out that someone took Tom
Brady's Jersey immediately in the locker
room right after the big game and I was
thinking to myself how is that even
possible have you seen a video it's out
which is have you watched it I am but
it's like I'm Sports report yeah right
apparently so I'm you know everything's
alleged like I don't think at this point
there's been an arrest but it was so Fox
has cameras all over the stadium
everywhere you can look and they've
actually put video out where you can see
him go in the locker room he follows
Bill Belichick he goes in kind of with
that Posse and then comes out with it
under his arm
you know allegedly it's it's insane
because I know my fiance tried to go and
work the Super Bowl hold the light that
was going you know I talk into the
camera and hold the light for me and he
had to basically give up his whole story
his whole life story how is this
possible right someone could walk into
the Patriots locker room and steal that
jersey it makes me think that I should
be stealing things left and right from
the NFL it's feels like they're not
really paying attention and we should
all just be wandering in there after a
game I just want a baseball hat that's
all I want you can't get one I mean with
the logo on it and everything yeah very
difficult I mean you can't get a
baseball hat well no a baseball hat with
the NFL logo like that there's a whole
basket of them
I know I'm sure I'll give you one except
mine are like a triple XL I have a knee
and I have the largest heads in
television thank you very much Kevin
mensch yeah he had a huge noggin what do
you have I don't know there's no size
for me okay they go they have nothing
they just have to construct a whole hat
but because I'm a Patriots fan they sent
me a bastion I'll give you one of mine
and we're good we can take it
you